the Federal Trade Commission is suing
Microsoft in an attempt to stop the
company's 69 billion dollar acquisition
of publisher Activision Blizzard the
suit which was filed December 8th claims
that the deal would make Microsoft too
strong a competitor in the video games
industry and would ultimately suppress
competition announced earlier this year
this purchase would give Microsoft
ownership over franchises such as Call
of Duty Diablo OverWatch and Candy Crush
throughout this process Microsoft has
repeatedly attempted to assure the
public that exclusivity is not its aim
with this acquisition the company has
reportedly guaranteed that the Call of
Duty franchise will remain on
Playstation platforms for a decade and
will also come to Nintendo consoles if
the deal goes through however the FTC
claims the acquisition still gives
Microsoft an unfair advantage and could
quote dampen innovation in these more
nascent gaming markets and according to
the Washington Post this lawsuit could
put a stop to Microsoft's purchase of
acne Bloods Microsoft has reportedly not
seen such a serious regulatory threat to
its business in over 20 years when the
Department of Justice brought an
Anti-Trust lawsuit against the company
in a press release from the FTC the
commission gave more insight into their
decision one part that caught my eye
says quote Microsoft decided to make
several of bethesda's titles including
Starfield and redfall Microsoft
exclusives despite assurances it had
given to the European Anti-Trust
authorities that it had no incentive to
withhold games from rival consoles in
other words the FTC is worried Microsoft
will change their mind about Call of
Duty exclusivity once the deal is
approved earlier this week Xbox boss
Phil Spencer spoke on the second request
podcast and reacted to Sony's stance on
Microsoft's Bid to Buy Activision
Blizzard Spencer said quote there has
really only been one major opposer to
the deal and it's so Sony is trying to
protect their dominance on Console the
way they grow is by making Xbox smaller
they have a very different view of the
industry than we do they don't ship
their games day and day on PC they don't
put their games into subscription when
they launch Spencer went on to say that
Sony grabbing onto Call of Duty in its
argument as to why the deal should not
be allowed to go through doesn't make
sense to him Spencer said Microsoft has
said repeatedly that it will not take
Call of Duty off PlayStation if it's
acquisition of Activision Blizzard goes
through
but okay depending on what time you're
watching this you may be preparing for
the game awards 2022. the official live
stream begins December 8th with a 30
minute pre-show at 4 30 PM Pacific Time
7 30 p.m eastern time followed by the
main show at 5 p.m Pacific 8 PM Eastern
Award winners will be announced from
over 30 categories across General gaming
and Esports including Game of the Year
best game Direction and a new Award for
best adaptation for a video game IP into
another form of media the event will
also feature announcements involving 40
to 50 games according to an epic games
interview with Jeff Keeley who has
called this year's event the biggest
show yet we'll be streaming the whole
thing right here at Gamespot so tune in
but make sure to keep the show open in
Steam as well on mute if you registered
to win a steam deck good luck
foreign